amo ho già detto che io non lo festeggio
natale l'uomo allora non lo vuoi il
regalo cosa ho fatto
zynga facendo base in gabella 20
novembre è sì barbara ci troviamo qui in
piazza del duomo è ufficialmente
iniziata la corsa alla ricerca del
regalo perfetto quest'anno inoltre gli
italiani spenderanno all'incirca il 30
per cento in più dell'anno scorso per i
loro acquisti di natale ecco vedi tutto
in giro a fare regali e poi dicono che
c'è crisi a chi è venuto in mente di
mettere i canditi nel panettone io odio
il panettone che pronuncia che siamo
solo la sua situazione di natale pandoro
tv io lo voglio
sì ma da gennaio palestra e smaltisco
tutto oddio non dovevi non dovevi
disturbarti davvero che bello c'è lo
scontrino un altro film di natale
basta ea te cosa hanno regalato una
poltrona per due
apriamo i regali cosa mi metto natale
amo guarda ho preso il perizoma per
capodanno non è bellissimo
mamma ho perso l'aereo marina mai
diventare di atri regali
grazie ai calzini grazie va beh facciamo
che iniziò a studiare a gennaio ragazzi
davvero non regalatemi nulla quest'anno
che bello questo orologio mi ricorda
tanto il mio me l'hanno appena rubato no
non ha spiegazioni e questa è la usiamo
il prossimo anno
miracolo nella 34esima strada basta cioè
fidanzato e quando ti sposi
[Musica]